what up everybody good morning happy
friday 9am here on the east coast time
for gratitude journal number 5 live
stream this is this is uh this is
potentially the end I want to know what
you guys think I committed to doing this
for a week I do this I do this every
week day with my team and I thought I'd
try it with you guys for a week and see
what you guys think so let me know in
the live chat in the comments if you
want this series to continue for 10
minutes every morning on the weekdays ah
the idea here is that we're sharing
things that we're grateful for and
important to start at least I think to
start your day with a little bit of
gratitude set yourself up on the right
place it's hard to be grateful for
something in and be upset and and hate
and be- at the same time and so I you
know my goal as an entrepreneur is be a
happy entrepreneur and gratitude is a
key part of that yes we want to strive
to do more yes we have big goals yes
we're frustrated that it's not moving
fast enough but equally were we're
grateful and happy with what we do have
and do appreciate things and the people
around us so something to with my team
and I'm excited that we've been bringing
it to you guys and yes do let me know if
you want this series to continue at the
same time leaving the live chat in the
comments below afterwards three things
that you are grateful for I'll share
three for me but this doesn't really
work for you doesn't have the impact
that I wanted to have unless you guys
are feeling it too so write down three
things that you're grateful for last
point before i get into mine is again
those three things have to be something
that you really feel that you really
think about it that you really kind of
embrace for a few seconds not just
listening through things off but you
actually feel the warmth to love the
gratefulness in your body so that can
carry through for hopefully the rest of
the day I'm so i'll get to mine i always
have to embody and think a little bit um
I'm really grateful for my friends ah
I'm an introvert by nature and so I
don't really have a need for my friends
have much also because the nature of my
business is so social like I'm always
doing interviews and meetings and with
trying to dance salsa a lot of nights
I'm out checking with chickening with
people and meeting people and so I need
a lot of alone in downtime so I don't
really have a strong need to hang out
with my friends much but what I'm
grateful for it's kind of awkward coming
it what I'm grateful for is that I know
there's a whole group of people would
have my back if I needed something if I
was going through something or I needed
help or any advice or just someone to
talk to i know there's a bunch of people
who would line up to to want to help me
out and so for that i'm extremely
grateful I'm grateful for four great
sleep when I get it I'm super grateful
for that last night or yesterday
afternoon a friend of mine was going
through some tough stuff and I can't
help but in body and take on other
people's emotions in it it stresses me
out and so I didn't have a great sleep
last night but that helps me appreciate
good sleep you know like sometimes you
need the rains appreciate and really
appreciate the Sun so I'm grateful when
I get a good night's sleep and I'm
grateful that I'm good for that my
sister came back my younger sister was
in Africa for a good part of a decade
working for the UN and doing a whole
bunch of dangerous missions trying to
help child soldiers that come out of the
the war and the kids again and all sorts
of crazy things where you worry about
you know it was my sister gonna make it
some of these days that she's a pretty
tough person but um she's back in
toronto now she's part of trying to
dance salsa and it's great to have it's
great to have her back and know that
she's safe and just being around so I'm
grateful for the
too cool so those are my three I want
you guys to leave it in the chair you
see some coming in so leave a damn I'm
gonna leave you guys some shoutouts as
we go through some of them here Rishi
Cup TV good morning everyone couple love
tgim tgim not yet we still got a couple
days before tgim I love the hustle
though oh I mean tgif LOL i love it
Alexander's I am grateful for having the
opportunity to learn about business have
an 11 family and having a healthy body I
love it Zeno I'm grateful for my right
knee that is that has been through a lot
but might now be stronger than ever i
love the body parts it's like that was
saying you're almost setting up for body
part of the day that Yuri perform is
interesting lot yesterday was that the
arm or the hand left hand I feel what it
was um I like it I like it grateful for
number 2 J reyez jerez is in the house
jerez sitting on at the table next wing
years juniors for a conversation that we
had yeah i was jumping behind
conversation we had yesterday during one
of the streams i can i can see how he
how he could help people build empires
love it a number through my backpack
that allows me to carry stuff in a
pretty convenient way i love it man and
i encourage you guys to to think about
little things like yes your right knee
is great yes a meaningful conversation
with somebody who's helped you but a
backpack like I'm grateful for my hat
and my sweater and you know the teeth I
have in front of me doesn't have to be
some big huge thing in fact I encourage
at least one of your things to be
something something I don't say mundane
but something not as not as a higher
priority as you know your family and
parents and you know big things little
things are important too to be grateful
for new future builder I'm people for my
fortitude for the random kindness that
people express and that I have a son
that looks up to me I love that man I
love it what else do we have Jay rises
saying yay
what's your witty big before uh I wrote
it in the chat but I am grateful for
connect hear me can you hear junior kids
get up she's coming in yet cameo
appearance we got three minutes all
right I am grateful for the abundance
loving supportive people in my life uh
whether their friends or family or
clients or strangers or acquaintances or
whatever love the people i'm grateful
for a quality attention like Zdeno thank
me in this in this chat I mean I'm I'm
I'm touched I'm honored I'm love I'm
grateful for Evan for including me here
now and I'm grateful to riot games for
creating one of them like the most
popular eSport in the world and we're
going to play that next two minutes I
love it man thank you for sharing bro
yes two minutes we're doing our league
of legends live stream entering business
questions um good was it that the first
cameo think his first cameo we've done
that might I think that is CJP grateful
for God Jesus and family tyrelle read is
grateful for my cognitive skills I love
it Rishi cup I don't have a need for my
friends at much hey come on this is this
is this is not this is not a trolling
morning oh I know I know I know she's
laughing at me I love you dude it's all
getting a little busy this is all good
what else we got what else we got much
much says awesome I am grateful to be
able to be here I love it much is
joining it's like six o'clock in the
morning over there eating for chocolate
we didn't have to do a chocolate for
Brian no I said the last time work
through a chocolate for breakfast one of
these times Cherie Mike what sorry
Cherie right my right knee to which is
shocked and I need a new one darn skiing
I hope you I hope your right knee is ok
this is good tyrelle is also grateful
for my artistic talents I've and I love
your videos shay here from the
Philippines I appreciate that shea
welcome aboard I guess it's a evening
there for you now I love it Shan Shan
Tara Lane love your channel so grateful
I found it I'm grateful that you found
it too I'm grateful that you're joining
us here on this morning live stream what
else we got good morning are you in your
PJs uh-oh she's talking too much I am
NOT in my pjs as you can see although I
might sleep in this um but yes much
white that she is in her pjs well that's
it guys I know there's more comments
coming in but it's 10 minutes and so I
appreciate the love if you want this
series to continue leave a comment down
below let us know and continue to leave
the three things that you're Greek
before hopefully have an amazing day you
want to hear some business QA you can
hop on the twitch channel now to join me
Russia cup TVJ our eyes maybe coach 6 on
a game have an amazing day guys have an
amazing end of the week rocket today
last day let's get some action happening
you to believe or whatever your one word
is help see soon